[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello friends we're gonna have an
amazing fact now that's even a little
sad at least 35 people were killed and
several dozen are missing after a tragic
landslide near Addis Ababa
on March 11 2017 landslides rarely
killed people in Ethiopia but this was
not your typical landslide of dirt or
mud but rather a landslide of garbage
the kosh a rubbish landfill on the
outskirts of odda Saba has been dumping
ground for the nation's capital for more
than 50 years each year almost 300,000
tons of waste are collected and piled on
this mountain of refuse every day as
mobs of crows circle overhead about 500
people sift through the apocalypse of
stinking rubbish looking for anything
they might be able to scavenge and sell
over time these poor scavengers had
built their homes of mud and sticks
directly against the ever-growing
precipice of trash it was one of these
many makeshift homes and their occupants
that were buried by the massive
avalanche of rubbish just outside the
Ethiopian capital so how do you escape a
looming mountain of garbage stay with
his friends we're going to learn more as
amazing facts brings you this edition of
Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at one
eight hundred
says that's one eight hundred four sixty
three seventy to ninety seven now let's
join our host pastor Doug Batchelor and
our co-host pastors Jean Ross
welcome listening friends to Bible
answers live and we have lines open if
you've got a Bible question that's why
we're here it's a free phone call the
number 800 god says eight hundred four
six three seven two nine seven one more
time with your Bible questions eight
hundred four six three seven two ninety
seven we're gonna make the best possible
use of the technology of radio to talk
about the Word of God my name is Doug
Batchelor my name is John Ross good
evening listening Franzen pastor Doug
like to begin the program with a word of
Prayer dear father in heaven thank you
for the opportunity for us to spend a
few moments together opening your word
and studying these important Bible
truths on the ask for your Holy Spirit
to come in God our minds Lord as we
search the Scriptures to know the truth
and to know him who is the truth for we
ask this in Jesus name Amen amen
pastor doc you open the program by
talking about a avalanche but somewhat
unusual of course you've got avalanches
of snow and avalanches of mud and dirt
but boy an avalanche of just garbage and
then to suffer the terrible consequences
of being buried by carbage is just it's
a sad fact you know it is it it's a
tragedy and it's also ironic but you
know it's so sad that people would have
to live and you've seen that you've
travelled a lot and and I've seen it
obviously last year we were there at a
SATA bar in you oh that's right now I've
not been there yet I just I've seen the
place it's poor people that need to live
by city dumps in India and other places
and and that is a tragedy but it's hard
to imagine it piled so high that it
becomes a mountain that kind-- well last
count they were thirty-five people
confirmed dead and many more missing
this just happened at the time of this
recording yesterday
and so I thought you know a lot of
people feel like they're being crushed
by a mountain a mountain of sin it
reminds me one time of a little girl
that heard her Sunday school teacher
reciting the Lord's Prayer and when
explaining it to her friend you know it
says were forgive us our trespasses as
we forgive those who trespassed against
us she told her little friend she said
we forgive others their trash baskets as
we forgive them for putting trash in our
baskets and sin is kind of like trash
matter of fact in the Bible Jesus said
that one of the ways he describes the
loss it says they would be go to Gehenna
and Gehenna was a valley outside of
Jerusalem that was the city dump it was
full of worms it was ever-burning that's
why Jesus said where the warn does not
die and the fire is not quenched and you
know it also talks in the Bible about us
all fina like we're under this burden of
sin all the garbage you might say you
can read in Ezekiel 33 10 there for you
O son of man say to the house of Israel
thus you shall say if our transgressions
and our sins lie upon us and we pine
away in them how can we then live it
just describes the people being crushed
by the weight of guilt and their sins
but then Jesus tells us that he's in the
business of moving mountains he can read
there for yourself in mark 11:22
jesus said have faith in God for I tell
you that whoever says to this mountain
be removed and cast into the sea and
does not doubt in his heart but believes
those things that he says it will be
done now when I first read that verse
about having mountain-moving faith I
thought oh this is a real trick if you
could just look at a big hill I wouldn't
even need Everest any old hill if I
could look at a hill and say let me see
if I can move that hill that really
would impress my friends I read a little
further in the Bible and discovered the
Lord's not talking about mountains of
dirt he's talking about having faith so
that we can trust in God's grace to move
the mountains of sin that crush us all
you can read in Micah 7:19 he will have
compassion on us he will cast our
sins into the depths of the sea so you
get that connection friends there's a
mountain of sin Jesus said if you have
faith you can move the mountain into the
sea and Myka says that he will cast our
sins into the depths of the sea most of
you can't recite all the sins you've
committed in the last week
much less through a year or your
lifetime it starts to add up until
pretty soon you have a mountain of guilt
some people think how can I ever change
look at this mountain but when you have
faith in God Jesus dying on the cross
provided the antidote that is powerful
enough and the grace to move an entire
mountain of sin and maybe you'd like to
be out from under that crushing weight
of garbage friends the Lord tells us in
his word you can through faith in His
grace we have a free offer that talks
about it tonight we've got a book
entitled the riches of His grace and
this is a free offer for this evening
anybody listening I would like to call
and ask we would be happy to send it to
you the number to call is 883 five six
seven four seven that is our free offer
a book entitled riches of grace for
anyone wanting to learn how we can be
free of those sins that seem at times a
mountain of garbage in our lives while
there's good news
riches of His grace the number to call
for that free book is 883 five six seven
four seven and if you have a Bible
question our phone lines are open it's a
good time to give us a call the number
is 800 four six three seven two nine
seven that number again is 800 four six
three seven two nine seven with your
Bible question that'll bring you right
here into the studio well pastor doc I
think we're ready to go to the phone
lines our first caller is a guy
listening from Ohio guy welcome to the
program yes thank you I had a question
about the little time of trouble and I'm
just wondering is that an actual phrase
that's in the Bible and also how will we
know when we are in or approaching a
little time of trouble yeah you don't
find the phrase I don't think pastor
Ross little time of trouble in the Bible
many Bible scholars agree that
the tribulation actually comes in a
couple of phases you read in Revelation
13 that at one point those that do not
capitulate to the beast power cannot buy
or sell now that'll be bad that'll make
life difficult and Christ talks about
you know those that be in Judea flee
into the mountains there might be a time
where we've got to run and live off the
land so to speak like John the Baptist's
eat locusts and wild honey but the big
time of trouble is when the Beast goes
to the next step and there's a death
decree whoever would not worship the
image of the Beast should be killed and
so some scholars have separated the two
by calling one the small or little time
of trouble and the other is the big time
of trouble the big time of trouble also
happens after probation closes and the
seven plagues are falling when the big
time of trouble begins people cannot be
saved or lost the saved are sealed and
the lost are lost and that's where you
find in revelation 22 oh I forget the
verse it's verse 11 maybe where it says
let the just be just still the filthy
filthy still revelation 22 yeah so I
don't know if that makes sense
guy yeah wondered so we're technically
we're not in the little time of trouble
it just seems like the way the world's
going there's so much turmoil that makes
you think that maybe we're closed yeah
well you know Jesus said when he talks
in Matthew 24 there's gonna be wars and
rumors of wars they'll be nation rising
against nation there's gonna be famines
he said all these are the beginning of
Sorrows in other words there's gonna be
problems all through history and we've
seen that but finally things are gonna
get to the point well there'll be a
confederacy of religious powers that are
gonna force the world to worship a
certain way and if they don't it's gonna
be they're gonna make it difficult at
first I'll try and encourage everybody
by economic sanctions if you will
can't buy or sell that's what that is
then when that doesn't work to to sway
those who are faithful to God
they're gonna make a death decree and I
suspect shortly after they make the
death decree the seven last plagues will
begin to fall probation closes
and it's going to be that's why Jesus
said it's a time of trouble such as
never has been you look at the seven
last plagues in Revelation look at what
happened to Egypt during the Exodus and
even the people in needs have told the
Pharaoh do you not know that Egypt is
ruined and imagine that happening on a
global scale is it is it true or
understood that the seven last plagues
will occur within like a one-year period
or we're longer or shorter well I'll
tell you where the the I think everyone
believes is going to be a year or less
because it says in a day her plagues
will come so uh yeah I'm of the opinion
that means that it all happens within
one year I don't think it will take a
whole year I compare the seven last
plagues to you know the sufferings of
job or even the plagues that fell on
Egypt they seemed to come in a matter of
you know a month or two months they were
kind of back to back but the saved won't
really experience the plagues watching
it happen right I think we're gonna be
protected because the children of Israel
during the seven last plagues that fell
on Egypt there were ten plagues that
fell on Egypt the Israelites suffered
during the first three right along with
the Egyptians but God protected the
Israelites during the last seven and
that's interesting in Revelation there's
only seven plagues so I think we're
preserved through that time thank you
very much thank you hey appreciate your
call guy or about I think if we have a
free offer dealing with that I don't
know if you have something yeah in the
book anything but secret we talked about
the tribulation oh that's right talking
about the second coming again
guy if you'd like to receive that book
we'll be happy to send it to you all
you're left to do is call our resource
phone number the number is 885 six seven
four seven you can ask for the book
called anything but secret and we'll be
able to send it to you it's talking
about the second coming of Jesus also
some of the events associated with the
coming of Christ and I think you'll find
it interesting
anybody listening give us a call that
resource number is 883 five six seven
four seven you can ask for the book
anything but secret and if you have a
Bible question good time to give us a
call the number is 800
six three seven two nine seven again
that's 804 63 72 97 with your Bible
question a next call is Leonora
listening from Washington
Lenore I welcome to the program thank
you evening I'm glad to be honest and
your question was wondering I was
talking to somebody on the bus a good
friend and he asked him if he was
baptized and he said no I don't have to
be and I said what do you mean and he
said well he says his Lord loves all
people with gray hair and he
automatically forgives them every sin
and I've never heard that no place yeah
I don't think I'd worry about getting my
theology
from people's whimsical ideas like that
I think that I told him you have to be
baptized yeah absolutely
the last words yeah the last words of
Jesus should be a priority for believers
where you know he said go therefore
teach all nations baptizing them and the
apostles when they began preaching first
thing they said is repent and be
baptized so baptism is really the
ceremony by which you publicly seal that
you have made a decision to commit your
life to Christ and believe in his
sacrifice and so yeah there you'll hear
all kinds of strange theories and so you
know some people think they get a pass
but there's no pay you know God doesn't
greet us on the curve he says this is my
word he wants us to he wants us to
follow
he keeps going that tell you what sherry
we have you know there'll be people in
heaven that we're not baptized
biblically or they did not know you know
sin is knowing to do good not doing it
and he may just not understand we have a
free offer we'll be happy to send you a
copy and it's the book is
perfect is right up the alley it's
called baptism is it an is it necessary
and so when we send you a free copy of
this book you can maybe share it with
your friend when you see him again and
just say take a look at this and let me
know what you think it's all Bible based
and I think everybody if they believe
the Bible they read that book they'll be
pretty clear again the book is called
baptism is it really necessary and the
number to call for that is 883 five six
seven four seven and for those who are
listening who have access to the amazing
facts or website you can actually read
the book for free online just amazing
facts dot o-r-g the book again is called
baptism is it really necessary our phone
line here to the studio is eight hundred
four six three seven two nine seven if
you have a bible question eight hundred
four six three seven two nine seven a
next caller is hazel listening from
Queens New York
hazel welcome to the program okay I have
two questions that I stick with the one
that I asked your receptionist how did
the word Church got into the Bible is
that an original Greek or Hebrew word no
good good question the word that we use
for church is actually a I think it's a
Celtic word that it comes from the word
Kirk and it's not the the word I think
the word church is ekklesia but our
modern our English word Church actually
comes from a word is it a Gaelic or a a
Celtic word but it's it's not the Greek
and so it just translates that way for
in English
yeah the wording the Greek has more of a
interpretation that leans towards
assembly it is the gathering of
believers so the word there in the Greek
that's used for church
means assembly or gathering and people
understood that though to me more than
just getting together for a visit its
gathering or assembling for the purpose
of worship for the purpose of
celebrating communion for the purpose of
encouraging one another in spiritual
things but that's the root meaning
meaning simply assembly or gathering
together also translated Church yeah and
then the I think it's very similar to
the word synagogue which also means
gathering but some of our listeners will
remember a hymn that you would find in
your in your books it's called come to
the Kirk in the Wildwood and it's
actually drawn from the head Old English
word for church they used to call it the
Kirk and so we're using sort of a
corruption of that old word but it's
nothing like the Greek word for ecclesia
anyway that's a good question here's a
lesson we just gave you a little
entomology you have the work shirts
there you mean you mentioned that pass
today
okay sure a real quick question okay you
know he died on a cross I know that our
Jehovah Witness friends make a big issue
you're saying he didn't actually die on
a cross that he died on a straight pole
like a fence post or a stake but my
scripture for that would be of course
the word cross is used and secondly when
Jesus told Peter how he was gonna die he
said when you are young you girded
yourself you go where you wanted this is
John 21 I think and but when you're old
another will gird you and you will
stretch forth your hands now if a person
stretches forth their hands they would
put them out in front or out to the side
you would not put them overhead the the
Jehovah Witnesses found that there are
some cases in histories where the Romans
crucified a person all they had was a
pole and so they did crucify some that
way but traditionally they did it on the
cross where the arms spread out and so
kind of like when Samson died he
stretched out his arms and laid down his
life and this is what Jesus did Moses
before when the children of Israel were
fighting the Amalekites he went on the
mountain he stretched out his arms
interceding and Aaron and Hur had to
and on the right and the left and hold
his arms out perpendicular from his body
if his hands were overhead it wouldn't
have been near his heart so you do have
that I think the example it was across
in the Bible okay thank you much what
Scripture was that John 21 do you have
that pass yeah John 21 verse 18 thank
you appreciate your question you know
pastor like we have a book called the
high cost of the cross and I think hazel
will enjoy reading the head or anybody
who calls an ass the number is 883 five
six seven four seven you can ask for the
book called the high cost of the Cross
I'm a Baptist send that to anybody who
calls and asks our phone line here to
the studio is 800 four six three seven
two nine seven eight hundred God says
800 four six three seven two nine seven
that's the acronym by the way God says
means four six three seven two nine
seven annex caller is sherry listening
from Washington
sherry welcome to the program Cherie
you're on the air are you there and your
question no problem
well I remind me at the end maybe a
question will give you a different
number that you you can call them will
will send you the booklet thank you so
much I really appreciate that I would
like to know if you don't hear much
teaching or preaching on the counterfeit
gift
of the Holy Spirit what they are what
they can do how they can be deceived
people how they can almost destroy
people if they're unaware of that if
they don't know the Lord and I would
like to know first of all I started
searching for Jesus at 19 after a
head-on car accident I went to many
different types of churches throughout
the East Coast and up to Washington
I saw many manifestations of what
appeared to be church but I never found
Jesus and all these years of searching I
only found well I wouldn't know the
difference that they were counterfeit I
didn't really know evil but there were
all kinds of manifestations of these
gifts and people and bad bad things
happening I got thrown around rooms Ruth
my family witnessed much I could never
get away from it you know we actually
might didn't we have a book on
counterfeit gifts you do yeah well at
least one of them and but I think I
think it's up the alley of what you're
talking about right and if you'd like we
can send you a free copy and when we
will transfer you back to the resource
line and we've got a book called
understanding tongues and that's one of
the gifts that you'll find in many of
these churches that is misunderstood we
believe in all the gifts of the Spirit
but there's also as you said there's a
counterfeit for every truth of God the
devil's got a counterfeit of love
there's even some counterfeit fruits of
the spirit so yeah we'll be happy to
send you that and we also want to get
you connected with whatever booklet it
is you wanted to request okay sherry let
me give you this number I want to make
sure you get it this is our resource
phone number and if you give them a call
I'll be happy to get you the books and
it's free all you got to do is just give
them a call the number is 883 five six
seven four seven I want to say that
again that's 800 835 67 46
and you can just go ahead and ask for
the book called understanding tongues
that's the one that we mentioned now or
any previous books that we mentioned on
this program and our goal here at Bible
answers live is to get into the word
study these important biblical truths
and so we hopefully provide some useful
resources for people in that endeavor so
again I thank you for your call sherry
and hopefully you'll be able to get some
of that material our next caller is
Janet listening from Texas Janet welcome
to the program yeah the the word repent
does not always mean there's a good
repentance there's a bad repentance
there's a repentance where you're caught
ah
and you'll acknowledge but it doesn't
mean it's going to be redemptive if you
read in the Old Testament when all the
plagues were falling on Egypt
when the plague was really intense the
Pharaoh would call for Moses and Aaron
they'd come in and he'd repent and say
I've sinned just you know take away the
plague and and I'm sorry and he'd put
make him all kinds of promises to change
his ways and as soon as the plague was
gone and he wouldn't change he was not
sorry for his sin fara was sorry about
the consequences
so you'll notice when when Peter
repented Peter went out and he wept
bitterly and he was a different man it
broke his heart when Judas repented
Judas just for sorry overwhelmed with
the guilt of what he had done in the
consequences but there it was more like
a sorrow that he had been caught and he
had pretty much at that point grieved
away the Holy Spirit you know there's
another story in the Bible of a man
named Aiken Aikens stole from the Lord's
Treasury when they actually they
plundered
Eriko he stole some of what was
designated for God's Treasury and he
would not admit it even after terrible
things were happening to the country
because of his secret sin finally when
they cast lots and the lot fell on Aiken
he admitted his sin and he said all yeah
I'm sorry
well he wasn't sorry he was just sorry
got busted so that's kind of what
happened to Judas is he was overwhelmed
with a sense of condemnation and all of
the lost are going to experience what
Judas experienced but they're gonna
experience it too late there will be a
time when they you know feel terror of
their sin but they've they've spurned
all the mercy while there was time well
thank you very much yeah I think Paul
refers to it as a repentance not to be
repented of genuine repentance and it's
the goodness of God that leads us to
repentance that's the kind of repentance
that we want
I appreciate your call very much Janet
and by the way friends that does open up
another line or two I think if you want
to call in with a Bible question we've
got another half who knows might be the
best half of this program coming and
that number is 866 to do 804 6 3 7 2 97
don't go very far because we're coming
back with Bible questions those of you
standing by now be patient and your
patience will be rewarded and while I'm
thinking about it friends amazing facts
offers wonderful materials all week long
at our website and the address there is
amazing facts dot o-r-g you can listen
to archives of this program we've got
books a lot of the resources that we
offer and much much more amazing facts
dot o-r-g we're coming right back
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
find out what the critics are raving
about top scholars and theologians from
around the country come together to
reveal the hidden history of the book of
Revelation with powerful reenactments
and incredible visual effects this 95
minute masterpiece brings to life the
book of Revelation like never before
revelation is no longer a mystery get
your copy today visit iTunes or AF
bookstore calm
in six days God created the heavens and
the earth for thousands of years man has
worshiped God on the seventh day of the
week now each week millions of people
worship on the first day what happened
why did God create a day of rest does it
really matter what day we worship who is
behind this great shift discover the
truth behind God's law and how it was
changed visit Sabbath truth com can't
get enough amazing facts Bible study you
don't have to wait until next week to
enjoy more truth filled programming
visit the amazing facts media library at
aft vor G at aft vor G you can enjoy
video and audio presentations as well as
printed material all free of charge
24 hours a day seven days a week right
from your computer or mobile device
visit aft vor G every Bible question you
have answered moves you one step closer
to the fullness of God's will for your
life so what are you waiting for get the
answers you need for a fuller richer
more confident life you're listening to
Bible answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call
[Music]
we are back listening friends that about
to go to the phones will remind you we
do have a line or to open that number
once more for six three seven two nine
seven this is amazing facts Bible
answers live a live interactive Bible
study you can participate by listening
and call in with your Bible related
question or some question about living
the Christian life we'll do our best to
search the word together
I'm Doug Batchelor my name is John Ross
and the past that are we ready to go
back to the phone lines our next caller
is Jim and he's listening in Huntsville
Alabama Jim welcome to the program hey
how you doing good hey you got a good
voice for radio Jim thank you my
question is I was always raised thinking
that like if you die you're gonna go to
the judgement and when you're judged
you're gonna go to heaven or you're
gonna go to hell and I was always raised
you know watching TV and everything else
like if you go to hell you're going to
eternal torment and a while back I'm
homeless and I go to the local humane
society and a lady there gave me a
booklet and it told me that you know God
is a loving God which I know God is a
loving God and it said that when you die
you're gonna go to the judgment and if
you go to hell it's the second death now
I know I've read that in the Bible but
I've not been able to find it so my
question is is do you go to eternal
torment or do you go to obliteration
alright well first of all the verse
you're looking for is in Revelation is
it 21 and 22 22 22 the second death and
there's two extremes when it comes to
the subject of Hell some people try and
say there is no hell it's just a
metaphor and other people talk about
Hell in this medieval concept of it's
just you know it's really horrific we
think about people blistering and sulfur
and brimstone for zillions of years it
doesn't matter how far you go you're
constantly feeling pain and agony and it
never ends and that's hard to comprehend
somewhere between those two are the
truth nee found the verse yeah actually
there's four four references to it and
all of them are in the book of
Revelation revelation chapter 2 11
revelation 20 verse 6 revelation 20
verse 14 and revelation 21 18 alright so
yeah now everybody dies the first death
that's what most people some will be
alive when Jesus comes I heard a pastor
say one time if you're only born once
you died twice but if you born twice
physical birth and spiritual birth you
only die once the first day you don't
have to worry about the second death but
there is a lake of fire this is the
between those two extremes you have to
be clear there is a place called hell
there is a lake of fire and Bible says
every man is rewarded according to his
what he deserves
saying that his angels are cast into the
lake of fire but what does it say
happened the obliteration exactly well
yeah each person suffers according to
what they deserve but it's not eternal
it means the results of it are eternal
there's no repentance no second chance
you read in Malachi chapter 4 the day is
coming that will burn as an oven and all
the proud and all that do wickedly will
be stubble it will burn them up the
Bible says that you have eternal life or
you perish John 3:16 that you'll be
devoured the wicked are consumed they're
burned up now don't spend too much time
thinking about Hell Jim because we want
you to think about heaven don't some
people have more questions about Hell
than they do about heaven I think well
where do you want to go yes oh but their
Bible is pretty clear there is a
punishment there is a lake of fire but
there it eventually the wicked burn up
it says there's not a coal to warm at it
says there's no more pain in Revelation
21 no more tears no more sorrow all
things are made new so the Bible is very
clear that God does not have a
never-ending torture chamber in the
cosmos where people are shrieking and
howling billions of people suffering yes
that's my main question can I give you a
real quick-like testimony yeah a couple
of years ago I became homeless not all
that detail but I went to Bankhead
National for
lived there with my dog for three months
and one day I woke up rolled over and
put my an on something it felt weird and
got bit by a cottonmouth oh my and it
took me I was six miles back in the
woods and I had a 50 pound pack the
first day I kept passing out my dog kept
waking me up and it took me two days to
get out of there when I did I was trying
to find a ride back Thomasville and some
people I talked to there they couldn't
give me a ride hook me up with a guy
that was a medic from the military and
he checked me out and everything and he
told me he said you you can't have been
bitten by a cottonmouth you should be
dead
and I said no you know I'm all right and
I pretty much lost my faith at that time
and he said you know you must be a very
strong person I told no I just I just
got Jesus riding shotgun with me that's
what it is and when I got back to
Huntsville I walked into Walmart my a
friend of mine was there and I was
taking gonna borrow a car to take my
gear to a friend of Mines house and I
walked in there and saw a shirt it was
when I got bit I had prayed and I just
said Jesus you know I mean I can do all
things if you just give me the strength
and when I walked in there I saw this
shirt just as soon as I walk around the
corner so Philippians 4:13 that I can do
all things through Christ strictly the
Lord spoke to you through that didn't he
well yeah I mean well he's got a special
plan for you and we think that he
planned for you to even call in tonight
Jim and you know what we have a free
offer that deals with your question that
will give you all the verses you know
there's actually two study guides on a
recommend to you for you tonight Jim the
one is dealing with the subject of Hell
you asked and it's called the study
guides called is the devil in charge of
Hell that you'll find that an
interesting read
but there's another study guide closely
connected with that same subject and
it's dealing with what happens to appear
when he dies it's called are the dead
really dead
and it talks about the resurrection
about the second coming of Jesus I think
you find it very encouraging we'll be
happy to send this to anybody who calls
an ass and Jim if you just asked for the
to study guides the one other dead
really dead and the other one is the
devil in charge of Hell we'll be happy
to send that to you for free the number
to call is eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven again it's
eight hundred eight thirty five sixty
seven forty seven and asked for the to
study guides the one dealing with death
meaning all they did really dead and the
other is the devil in charge of help
hey Jim thank you for that testimony you
know it made me think of a verse in the
Bible where the Apostle Paul was bit by
a deadly serpent but through the power
of God he was he lived through it great
testimony I next Coley is me me
listening from Texas Parker heights
Meany welcome to the program hi pastor
how are you doing good thank you for
calling and your question language lil I
know about I find that not appropriate
well you know if you go to the Bible I'm
sorry go ahead
Carson visiting you will want to know
what's going on here yeah it's exactly
what Paul says and not to do in 1st
Corinthians 14 you know whenever we
wonder about what we're doing you have
to say where's an example of that in
Scripture and nowhere in Scripture do
you see the Apostles and everybody
speaking incoherently you you do have
examples in the Bible where in Acts when
the disciples were speaking in tongues
those listening knew what they were
saying
and it says we hear them tell about the
wonderful works of God there's three
examples of speaking in tongues in the
Bible Acts chapter 2 Acts chapter 10
Acts chapter 19 in all three cases those
listening understood what they were
saying and there were several language
groups present now we've got a free gift
that deals with the subject of tongues
that talks about we believe in the gifts
of the Spirit and we believe in the gift
of tongues but with every gift of God
there's sometimes misapplications and so
we would encourage you to read this book
and look at what the Bible says about
the gift of tongues and how to use it
how not to use it but I think you you
know in your spirit maybe that there's
something wrong and we'll send you a
free copy yeah the book is called
understanding tongues talking about the
gift of the Spirit with reference to
tongues and we'll be able to send that
to anybody who calls and asks the number
is 883 five six seven four seven again
800 a three five six seven four seven
you can ask the book called
understanding tongues you can also go to
the amazing facts website just amazing
facts or g-type in the little search bar
understanding tongues and that'll take
you to a PDF version of the book and you
can read that right there online
our next caller is Gary listening from
Florida Gary welcome to the program
yes hello
hi Gary you're on thank you yeah I was
calling wondering what the pastor day
your opinion was of movies that are made
in Hollywood about the Bible and in
reference to that this recent one the
shack and wanted to get your opinion on
that you sort of kind of answer a little
bit from the previous caller the
gentleman who just or not the gentleman
us about the existence of hell and I was
listening to the program earlier on the
radio and saying that this particular
book and movie was complete biblical
heresy and then I was in my Bible study
group this morning before church and the
Bible leader and a couple other people
actually thought it was a fantastic
movie and endorsed it so I guess I'm
little
fused as to which way to head on this I
thought maybe you could provide some
insight all right well first I need to
divulge that I have not read the book or
seen the movie as a rule I don't go to
movies just because well for one thing I
most of what's produced in Hollywood is
not good but I do see them occasionally
when I'm flying or there's something
that's reproduced on television
most movies that try to portray the
Bible or a disappointment because it's
really hard to like you know do a video
of the Second Coming and you know they
usually recruit all kinds of love
stories and intrigue that are not really
in the story from what I've read about I
did read some reviews from people I
trust about this book called The Shack
and I guess the subsequent movie and
from what I have read it is heresy it's
it just completely departs from the
scripture that doesn't mean there aren't
going to be people out there that will
like it but just from what I've read
again I have to admit I've not read it
I've not not seen the movie I I'm very
suspicious that it's leading people the
wrong way you know pastor you mentioned
movies and Hollywood in the Bible for
those of you might not know your mother
played in movies and she was in a Bible
movie that's right not a very big part
but mom was she actually did I think two
or three movies with Charlton Heston
they did two or three movies together
they did another movie called The
Buccaneer my mom was in the number of
those movies done back then but yeah you
know Hollywood is they usually didn't
even like the Ten Commandments they've
got Moses having a love affair with
Pharaoh's wife and none of that's in the
bite
so anyway so I don't again
I don't recommend from what I've read by
people I trust about the book The Shack
I I don't think that I would recommend
it and I think it gets into spiritualism
and Eastern mysticism and and the movie
would be you know more of the same you
know I think part of the reason is if
people are gonna make a movie they want
to make money of the movie and they
don't necessarily want to
depict exactly what's in scripture
because well people can read the Bible
for themselves so they've got a kind of
ended their own twist to try and get
people's attention you you were saying
something else Gary I'm sorry yes no I
want to add to that saying that it
infers that a how can a good and
wonderful Almighty God have something
like hell where people are suffering for
eternal attorney and almost is it
depicted the fact that it would make
Jesus worse than Hitler and Nero and any
because of the fact that at least they
kill you know they tortured kill the
people they were done whereas saying
that the existence of hell people are
there's no end to the suffering well see
there may be some points in the movie
that are valid you know but I think they
go to the other extreme you know we
talked when we were answering that
question on Hell that there's two
extremes where people err one extreme is
that you know God has a torture chamber
through eternity where he's got billions
of people and the other extreme is that
there is no punishment there is no lake
of fire there is no hell and the Bible
is really clear that there is a
punishment there's a day of judgment
where people are going to be rewarded
good or evil and that's inescapable and
God is still a God of love and justice
and there's punishment so you know even
in America there if I don't know if they
still do it now but a lot of people when
they were sentenced they could get
sentenced to jail they could get
sentenced to hard labor so that there
was not just time but there was a hard
labor and so they were suffering Jesus
didn't just die for our sins Jesus
suffered and died for our sins and so
those who reject the sacrifice of Christ
they're going to suffer and die for
their own sins so that's pretty clear
does that make sense
Gary and then one final point that the
fact that you know I guess being someone
naive of I but now I've done my research
on the movie in the book and so here you
have my Bible study leader who I respect
a lot and a couple other guys who
very much more biblically scholarly than
I am and endorsing it and saying it's
great so I'm just wondering would be a
way to I mean do I kind of get in there
and become an objection as' and rabble
rouser or what would be a way to address
this if you're in my position
well you might let them know that you
respectfully disagree but as with most
movies it's a wave that will pass and
you don't want to you know do you want
to die on that mountain in your
relationship so you could let them in
the study group know that you view
things differently in a kind respectful
way if you have your reasons give your
reasons and then just move on and you
know he can be redemptive that way hey
appreciate your comments Gary and your
question I'm gonna have to look more
into that because I had not like I said
I hadn't even heard about what the
movies doing thank you very much all
right my next caller is Jamie listening
from Arkansas Jamie welcome to the
program thank you and my question is
baptism in the Old Testament how was
that accomplished from the time of Adam
and Eve to John Baptist
well there was no baptism as a
prerequisite to accepting Christ in his
kingdom of course Jesus had not come yet
there were types of baptism in the Old
Testament you can read where Naaman was
told to wash in the Jordan River seven
times and he was cleansed from his
leprosy a symbol of sin that later of
course became a type of baptism Paul and
first Corinthians says the nation of
Israel went through the Red Sea before
they were saved from the slavery of
Egypt and this was a type of baptism
Paul said they were baptized in the sea
when they went through the Red Sea so
there are symbols of baptism in the Old
Testament connected with salvation but
that wasn't really activated until the
Messiah came and so it's no longer
physical lambs but after John said Jesus
is the Lamb of God now you've got the
real baptism does that make sense yes it
makes sense all right well yeah we have
a lesson that will offer you also that
we mentioned earlier it's called baptism
is it really necessary
we'll be happy to send that to anybody
who calls and asks then I'm gonna call
he's 883 five six seven four seven you
can ask the book called baptism is it
really necessary all right well thank
you for your call Jamie and we have
another caller Phil who is listening
from New York Phil welcome to the
program yes we can hear you yeah you
have a great show I like your style you
know yeah you're obviously a very
knowledgeable guy but you speak plainly
I think you're getting it right well
bless your heart thank you for listening
tell your friends and enemies my
question sir is this I know that the
English word Jehovah comes from the
Hebrew word something like Yahweh but
the crazy question where does it a name
or the word Yahweh come from well if
everyone's gonna be honest I mean the
scholars that talk about this no one is
exactly sure how to pronounce the holy
name of God that some have translated
Jehovah others Yahweh or Yahweh because
the the Jews believed it was a sacred
name of God they only had the consonants
and they they most of the time if you're
reading that name in your Old Testament
in the King James Version you'll notice
there's you'll see the word Lord L
capital L small Ord and then every now
and then you'll see where it says
capital L capital o capital R capital D
usually wherever you saw the word Lord
in all caps that was the word Yahweh and
they would put a symbol and they thought
it was such a holy name they would never
pronounce it they would substitute the
name Lord or Elohim or something else so
it's a mystery how to actually say it
because it was considered the sacred
name of God and so you know I've heard
probably two or three or four different
derivatives of how people think it
should be pronounced okay no I
understand what you're saying I don't
want to take up too much of your time
but I know I will I know that in Hebrew
the vowels are not letters they're just
marks under under the letters but
you know the question of pronunciation
is not the same as the question of
origin have you any idea where the the
the consonants in the name originated
well if I'm not mistaken this is the
name that God gives to Moses when he
says who shall I say sent me and God
says I am that I am
and then he communicates the name
Jehovah to Moses and I kept a surah so I
could be wrong but I think that's the
first reference to that Holy Name in
Genesis when it says in the beginning
God created the heaven and the earth the
word Elohim is used which is a different
word and I think it's run into Jehovah
or what we called uova okay thank you so
very much and the second part of your
answer really does address and answer my
question and I thank you for your
consideration sir call anytime my next
call e is another film listening from
New York merit New York and Phil from
New York welcome to the program better
than we deserve or appreciate your
calling about you know why don't I
represent such as a weapon or a firearm
and it's the way that I've been raised
and I was taught about Jesus and being
fast and all that so my question is
around I think it's in Matthew and John
that it says that he who has something
about selling something and then
purchase a sword and then a few a few
verses later it says I think it's Peter
who says Lord I have two swords and
Jesus responded saying it is enough
they're using that to justify you know
listen do you need to have weapons you
know to protect your family to protect
also and so I'd like to know your
opinion on it all right well first of
all I don't believe it's wrong for you
know we're probably not talking about
buying swords because most people aren't
out there buying swords and by the way
if you get your radio on in the
background you might need to turn the
volume down or we're gonna you'll get
feedback Phil II you know where Jesus
says in Matthew 26
50 to put your sword in its place Peter
pulled out a sword to defend Jesus and
Christ has put away your sword for all
who take the sword will perish by the
sword now but when you get to Luke he
ends up saying look Lord we have two
swords and Jesus said it is enough well
Christ was basically saying there if if
you don't have anything sell your sword
and buy one he was talking in a metaphor
the sword is a symbol for the Word of
God and when the disciples that oh look
Lord we've got two swords and he said it
is enough he was basically saying enough
of this so that's and see if you look
and that's in Luke chapter 22 if you go
to verse 36 but now he who has a money
bag let him take it and likewise a
knapsack and he who has no sword let him
sell those garment and buy one he wasn't
really telling go show your clothes and
buy a sword he's saying make sure that
you're armed with a word of God and when
they said oh look we get two swords now
were they really gonna fight off the
Roman army with two swords and Jesus
would say yeah that's enough I only need
two swords when he told Peter to put
away so Jesus was rolling his eyes and
saying it is enough it's like when
Christ was crossing the sea and he said
beware of the leaven of the Pharisees
Jesus was using the symbol the teaching
of the Pharisees and the deceitful cell
Lord sorry we forgot to bring bread and
he said don't you get it I'm not talking
about bread I'm talking about the
teachings of the Pharisees so they often
misunderstood when Christ was using
parabolic language so yeah but you know
as far as a person owning a weapon you
know I I think that that's something of
a personal decision I would recommend
that if a person had a weapon as a
deterrent you know where I live up in
the hills you know we actually have wild
animals and so everybody up there has a
weapon just to scare off the Bears we
quite literally embarrass so I think
you're talking about the two-legged
bears and do we have weapons for them
you know we anyway I think the Bible
gives some pretty clear principles on
that but I appreciate your question and
hopefully we covered the sword part yes
thank you thank you very much all right
I think we have about two minutes we'll
try and get
the calling we have Harvey listening
from Washington Harvey you there yes we
left have your question quick my
question is I'm older and I can't
remember all the sins I've ever
committed I mean individually I mean do
they do I need to individualize each and
every sin or is there something in the
Bible that tells me where you know I
must be getting older too because I
can't remember all of mine and I find
comfort in knowing that I don't have to
remember and recite them all one by one
I see nowhere in the Bible where people
do that it is important to confess your
sin to God and I think that it would be
a good idea to just you know maybe kneel
some time with a copy of the Ten
Commandments
and you look at them and you say all
right Lord I know I'm a sinner and I am
guilty sin is the transgression of God's
law
if we have had other gods in our lives
if we have taken his name in vain Christ
said even false promises can be that if
we've had angry thoughts about others
that can constitute is murder if we
think impure thoughts Jesus said you can
commit adultery in your heart so all of
us have broken all of God's laws just
confess those to God and say search me
Lord if there's something I'm forgetting
reveal it to me the promises have we
confess and repent of our sins he will
forgive us our sins and cleanse us from
all unrighteousness you don't have to
remember them all just tell Lord I'm
willing to repent of all I know and
that'll cover it god bless you friends
we are out of time and want to remind
you go to amazing facts dot o-r-g and
help keep us on the air blessings
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
amazing facts began in 1965 with a God
inspired concept
hello this is Joe Cruz and the amazing
facts broadcast facts which affect you
each radio broadcast would begin with an
amazing fact from science nature or
history followed by a Bible message that
touched the hearts of listeners from
every walk of life the program was an
instant success and the ministry soon
began expanding to include Bible lessons
in 1986 amazing facts added the medium
of television to its growing outreach
efforts offering soul-winning
evangelistic messages for viewers around
the world
in 1994 pastor Doug Batchelor assumed
leadership of the ministry adding the
Bible answers live call-in radio program
and new ministry TV programs began
airing on multiple networks around the
world for 50 years the driving vision of
amazing facts has been the bold
proclamation of the everlasting gospel
and with a team of evangelists circling
the globe and thousands of men and women
being trained through the amazing facts
center of evangelism program Affco the
ministry is helping God's church see a
rich harvest of souls amazing facts
God's message our mission
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word visit our website at WWE
for our free Bible study course and make
sure to check out our online bookstore
at AF bookstore com which offers
thousands of inspiring books DVDs and
more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 pack so RG did you enjoy
this program make sure to tell your
family and friends tune in next time for
more Bible answers live honest and
accurate answers to your Bible questions
[Music]